[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god welcome to bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts international pastor john
ross
hello friends this is pastor john ross
pastor doug is out this evening but this
is bible answers live and how about an
amazing fact one of the most outstanding
flights ever made by any war pigeon took
place on october the 18th 1943 on the
day before the flight the british 56th
infantry division had requested air
support to assist them in breaking the
stubborn german defense lines in the
heavily fortified village of kovi vicia
in italy
however soon after the message was sent
the british suddenly succeeded in making
a surprise breakthrough without warning
the german resistance collapsed and
completely and the english troops
quickly overran the little town
the british quickly realized that this
unexpected victory would be disastrous
for them unless they could get word
through at once to call off the american
air support that they had so recently
requested if not they would certainly be
massacred by u.s planes as they now
occupied the very position that they had
asked to have bombed
it was at this point that they
discovered that they could not get word
of their danger to the airfield
all communications had broken down in
the hectic advance
there was no choice now but to rely
on to send their urgent message on one
of the pigeons always kept on hand for
just such an emergency
gi joe was the pigeon chosen to carry
this life or death message
flying swiftly over the battle torn land
the pigeon flew the 20 miles back to the
u.s air support base in 20 minutes
arriving just as the planes were warming
up to take off for their mission to
kovechia
the successful completion of this
historic flight saved the lives of more
than a thousand british soldiers
after world war ii gi joe was housed at
the u.s army's hall of fame in new
jersey along with 24 other pigeon heroes
and was awarded the medal of gallantry
the only bird or animal in the united
states to receive such an award
in march of 1957 he was placed with the
detroit zoological gardens where he died
on june 3 1961 at the age of 18.
now did you know friends that the bible
also talks about a life-saving message
that was carried by three angels well
stay tuned for more as amazing facts
brings you this edition of bible answers
live
well you know pastor carlos we
introduced the program by talking about
g.i joe this pigeon that had this life
and death message
an urgent mission and it was a timely
mission he had to get that mission back
to the air base to call off the air
support now in the bible we read about
an urgent message it's also a timely
message
and it has something to do with the
second coming of christ where do we find
this urgent message i think that the
message you're talking about is the
three angels message in revelation
chapter 14. that's right the three
angels messages of revelation chapter
14. you know revelation 14 is an
interesting chapter it begins by
describing a group of people called 144
and then you have this urgent message
the three angels message and then right
after the proclamation of the three
angels messages you have a prophetic
picture of the second coming of christ
jesus is pictured coming in the clouds
of heaven and he's coming to reap the
harvest of the earth so the message that
just precedes the second coming of
christ
is what we call the three angels
messages now i've got it here in front
of me so let me read at least the first
thing you don't have time to read all of
them but let me read the first angel's
message and you find that in revelation
chapter 14 verse 6 and this is what it
says and i saw another angel flying in
the midst of heaven having the
everlasting gospel to preach to those
that dwell upon the earth to every
nation tribe tongue and people saying
with a loud voice fear god and give
glory to him for the hour of his
judgment has come and worship him that
made the heavens the earth the sea
and the springs of water see here we
find the first angel's message is
calling people to worship god as the
creator it's announcing this judgment
hour that is
about to begin or has begun it's also
interesting to note that this message
has to go to every nation kindred tongue
and people because the second coming of
jesus is going to affect every nation
kindred tongue and people amen the
second angel talks about babylon says
babylon is fallen is fallen and then the
third angel's message is where we find
the most
fearful warning
anywhere in the bible it talks about the
beast power it says if anyone worships
the beast or his image or receives his
mark in his folder in his hand the same
shall drink of the wine of the wrath of
god
very important warning that we find
during that third angels message so
there might be some of you who are
listening and you might be wondering wow
never heard about the three angels
messages i want to learn more well we do
have a study guide it's one of our
classic amazing facts study guides it's
called angel messages from space and it
deals with the three angels of
revelation chapter 14. we will be happy
to send this to anyone who calls and
asks now pastor carlos you're going to
give us two numbers the one is the
number people need to call if they want
to get this free resource it's called
angel messages from space and if you
can't exactly remember that title just
ask for the study guide about the three
angels messages and they'll send that to
us so what is the number for the free
resources and what is the phone number
if people have a bible question they
want to call right into the studio now
great so if you uh wanting this free
offer you can call 1-800-835-6747
1-800-835-6747
if you want to call us and give us your
bible question you can also call us at
1-800 god says or
of 1-800-463-7297
that we have there
all right well pastor carlos before we
go to the phone lines we always want to
begin with prayer you know we recognize
the bible is god's book and if we're
going to understand it correctly we need
to guide us so why don't you start with
prayer father we thank you again for the
blessing and the opportunity to come
together and open your word uh we ask a
blessing for those that are calling and
may you give us discernment and wisdom
so that it may be your bible and your
word that answers not a human answer and
uh we may be blessed so we ask and beg
these things in jesus name amen amen
all right pastor carlos who do we have
first all right first we have martha
from chico california martha you are on
the air good evening
my question is in regards to
the six
seals
in revelation six
now i'm not sure because i just started
to study this morning i'm not sure what
the first field the conqueror
relates to
but in the others where it talks about
conflict and scarcity and
widespread death etc
i'm wondering if these aren't
um or
cannot be
applied to what our world is going
through today or if
this is something that's still
in the future okay yes good question
in the book of revelation we find three
series of sevens we have the seven
churches we have the seven seals and we
have the seven trumpets and then later
on we read about something called the
seven plagues and that's a separate item
but the seven churches the seven seals
and the seven trumpets they cover
roughly the same time period of
christian history from the time of the
early church where around 31 a.d when
jesus ascended to heaven and the
apostles began to preach
all the way through to our time you can
find that addressed in these series of
of
sevens
so the seven churches deal with church
history the seven seals deal with
experiences that god's people go through
during the christian era and the seven
trumpets deal with wars or judgments
that come during that time period
specifically talking about the the first
seals or the seven seals find this in
revelation chapter six the first seal
describes the first
century of christianity from about 3180
through to 100 a.d this is the time of
the apostles
you'll notice the opening of the first
seal describes a rider on a white horse
and he's given a crown and he's going
forth conquering and to conquer it's a
symbol of the gospel going forth being
preached by paul and others
even now one of the disciples thomas
went all the way to india to preach the
gospel so their white horse represents
that first 70 years when the gospel was
spreading so rapidly throughout the
roman empire the next is a red horse and
the red horse is a symbol of persecution
that came upon the christians from about
100 to
313 a.d
terrible persecution that came from
pagan rome and the reason for that is
because the christians refused to
acknowledge the emperor of rome as a
deity or as a god and so they faced all
kinds of opposition so red is a symbol
of blood it describes that time of trial
that persecution that came upon the
church the next horse just real briefly
is described as a black horse
that describes the time period after 3
13 when you have the legalization of
christianity and over the centuries that
followed all kinds of pagan practices
found their way into the christian
church
and that leads into the dark ages as we
know and during the dark ages which is
the fourth uh horse or the fourth seal
it describes the time of death and
famine and this was really a description
of what was happening in western europe
in the christian nations of western
europe at this time there was a terrible
plague called the bubonic plague known
as the black death that killed an
estimated
quarter
of the population of western europe
that's one in four people died from
you know the black death so there was a
terrible time that happened there during
the dark ages
uh the next seal talks about the
reformation persecution so the seals
have a historical application however
there are
different aspects of the seal that we
find echoed in the seven last plagues
and we know that the seven last plagues
is yet in the future
now jesus said one of the signs of the
last days would be an increase in
pestilence and pastor carlos it seems
like
we're seeing an incredible increase in
disease and of course we're in the midst
of a global pandemic so i think that is
one of the signs that we are nearing um
you know what the bible says we're
nearing closer to the second coming of
jesus does that help martha
yes it did and i thank you for your time
and your wisdom and i really appreciate
it all right thank you for your call
all right next we have brittany from
here sacramento california good evening
brittany you're on the air
what does the bible say about
persecution
all right what does the bible say about
persecution well persecution comes
to those who are standing up
for what they believe to be true now
there is good persecution but there can
also be bad persecution
uh there are those who stand up for
things that are not true and they might
face oppositional trials or persecution
but from a biblical perspective
throughout christian history
those who have stood for the truths of
the bible they did face opposition at
some times the persecution was terrible
at other times it wasn't as intense but
if we were standing up for bible truth
we will face opposition because
those who are opposed to the light
they don't want you to be sharing your
faith they don't like that and so yes
those who try to live a godly life will
face trials and persecutions jesus faced
trials when he was on the earth his
disciples face trials and in the last
days according to the three angels
messages the bible speaks of those who
are true to god they also will face
persecution and trial but god will
sustain them and carry them through so
yes the bible does talk about trials and
persecutions coming upon believers does
that help brittany
yeah it's great i'm going through that
now because i have this class assignment
and it's drawing me crazy because i'm
only spending
three plus days worrying about it and
it's driving me nuts
well you're right there are all kinds of
things that we face from day to day some
more important like a class assignment
if you're getting a grade that's an
important thing
and sometimes you just got to say lord i
need your help and the bible tells us to
cast all our cares upon jesus for he
cares for us that doesn't mean we don't
have to do our part right we always want
to do the best we can so we do
everything we can and then we leave the
results with god we just put our trust
in him
thank you for your call brittany who do
we have next
next we have jose from puerto rico good
evening jose
thank you my question is regarding the
this is suffering it is if the digital
suffering is a by-product of our trends
out of our transgressions
or our requirement for our salvation
and the question is anchored in the for
example isaac 53 yeah the sovereign
serpent uh so we're in servant
okay all right thanks for your call jose
i think we've got uh we cut off there
just a little bit at the end but i think
we've got the gist of your question
there
um christ's suffering or his persecution
on the earth was that in order to obtain
salvation for us
or was that an example of of his
righteousness
both i think on the one hand
all of our problems everyone has sinned
and come short of the glory of god we're
in need of righteousness
and of ourselves we cannot produce
righteousness but jesus lived a perfect
life from his birth till his crucifixion
a perfect life a perfect life of
righteousness
not only did he die for our sins
but he also lived a perfect life for our
uh salvation as well so when we accept
jesus our personal savior not only are
our sins paid for but his life of
righteousness stands in the place of our
lives of unrighteousness and we stand
before god just as if we have never
sinned so yes the trials that jesus went
through were very real
and uh we can claim his life of
righteousness on our behalf so that's
the the biblical truth the theological
term there pastor us justification where
we're accepted before god
just as if we have never sinned we are
clothed in christ's robe of
righteousness amen and that same power
that was manifested in his life is also
given to us to participate in the divine
nature and the theological term for that
is called sanctification so not only
does he forgive us
but he transforms us amen and then that
leads to our final hope and that is
glorification glorification is when
jesus comes again when these mortal
bodies put on immortality because that's
the great hope of the christian thanks
for your call jose who do we have next
trent from austin texas hello trent you
are on the air welcome just want to let
you know i'm a former asco student from
2015 so oh good to talk to you again all
right great um
yeah so my my question is in ezekiel
chapter 40 through 48
um there's that long prophecy of the
vision that ezekiel had about um a third
temple being built and i was wondering
is that the one that's been talked about
that's been built in um the
on the new earth during the millennium
or in heaven in the millennium or
what temple is that supposed to be
exactly okay how do we know all right
there's two parts to that temple that's
been described um the temple described
that we find in ezekiel is really a
description now bear with me is a
description of the church triumphant the
characteristics given of that temple is
a description of god's people empowered
by the holy spirit going forth to the
nations of the world preaching the
gospel there's a great revival that
takes place so
that temple has a symbolic application
now if israel had been faithful and they
had fulfilled all of the requirements
that god had placed perhaps in a very
real sense that temple could have
existed here on the earth but
the covenant required an agreement on
both sides and unfortunately israel fell
short in that they eventually rejected
the messiah and as you know christ ended
up being crucified but in the bible we
find five different types of temples or
sanctuaries you have the heavenly that
you read about in hebrews you have the
earthly the one that moses built in the
wilderness you read about in exodus and
then of course you also have another
temple that solomon built and then the
one that was rebuilt after the seven
years of babylonian captivity that's all
the earthly
and then jesus said speaking of himself
destroy this temple and in three days i
will raise it up again so christ is
described as a temple and then the bible
says no you're not that your body is the
temple of the holy spirit so if the holy
spirit is working within us
we're
a temple a temple for god and then i
think the one that connects with this
passage in ezekiel uh the bible says no
you're not that you living stone
speaking of the church
and christ is the cornerstone and we all
built up together so this uh temple
description here is a description of
god's people especially in the last days
that are taking the everlasting gospel
to the world
hope that helps trent
all right next we have e frank from new
york
yeah yeah pastor um
ross and pastor carlos i have a question
for you gentlemen tonight that
i'm concerned in regards
but first i would just like to thank a
child that was on your show many many
months ago named alexander who inspired
me to make this call he seemed like a
nice child that was very helpful in me
figuring out that this is not the way to
uh believe in christ
because i've been believing for many
many years in celebrating easter
in a christian way which i discovered
was not christian by believing in
figures like the easter bunny easter
candy
and other pagan beliefs and my question
for you gentlemen tonight is is it uh
written in the bible that those things
like the easter bunny and other
fictitious characters
are not
found in the bible and they are not
christian because
it leads to a form of paganism because i
always thought that maybe believing in a
very uh
fictitious uh rabbit that's giving candy
on a certain time of the period period
of time of the year was not such a bad
idea but when i read the bible i saw
that those were pagan beliefs yeah well
let me say something about that frank
thanks for call all right so first of
all does the resurrection of jesus have
anything to do with uh easter eggs or or
rabbits or bunnies and the answer of
course is no the whole idea of easter
you don't find the word easter in the
bible now in the king james version
you'll find the word easter but a more
accurate translation of that is actually
a reference to the passover you'll find
that in the new king james and other
translations today it used the word
passover so during during the middle
ages from 313 80 onwards as christianity
was legalized in the roman empire there
were a number of pagan practices that
came into the church
in an attempt to try and draw in the
pagans
and uh even some pagan holidays or pagan
icons eventually got christian names uh
even some pagan statues were renamed
after certain bible characters but they
were actually pagans statues so when it
comes to easter or it comes to
celebrating the resurrection of jesus
yes there are some pagan trappings that
you find there um
now you know to celebrate the
resurrection of jesus i mean that's
that's a wonderful thing and the bible
celebrates his resurrection you know
from cover to cover in the old testament
symbols and types and in the new
testament you have the stories of the
resurrection of jesus uh the bible does
tell us though that baptism is the
symbol that god has chosen baptism by
immersion to celebrate his resurrection
death to the old resurrection to the new
life but to remember the resurrection of
jesus around
the passover is by no means wrong but i
think we need to be careful
in trying to place some value on these
pagan ideas that have kind of
come into christianity you know we do
have a book pastor carlos it's called
baptized paganism and we'll be happy to
send this to anybody who calls and asks
and it'll kind of give you some of those
pagan origins of some traditions that
have found their way into the christian
church and i think you'd find that
interesting if you were to read that
just call and ask for the book baptize
paganism 1-800-835-6747
all right thanks for calling frank who
do we have next
jeff from arizona you are on the air
welcome jeff
hey good evening guys um real quick
before i ask my uh question um i'm not a
seventh-day adventist but we are
basically 99 identical
um
you know i i believe you know sabbath is
saturday yes absolutely uh baptism by
immersion you know everything you know
um
we're pretty much identical uh question
i have is to do with um soul sleeping so
in um
matthew
what is it matthew 27 verse 38 i think
it is where the thief on the cross you
know tells jesus hey master you know
don't forget me
and jesus said you know today you will
be with me in paradise so
is
the term paradise is that like a um
is that speaking of him actually as one
of the very few that are in heaven
all right good question what about that
passage that you find it's actually in
luke where it talks about uh jesus
saying to one of the thieves on the
cross i think carlos is looking up the
verse for us there in luke so there's
two thieves on either side of jesus the
one is uh saying if you are the christ
then come down from the cross and save
us that's what one of the thief the one
of these are saying apparently both of
them at first were saying that but as
the one was listening to what was
happening observing what was happening
conviction took a hold of him and he
finally turned to the other thief and
said you know we're getting what we
deserve but this man speaking of jesus
he has done nothing wrong and then the
holy spirit even illuminated his mind
more because he finally turns to jesus
and he says master remember me
when you come in your kingdom.
now it's important for us to note the
thief was not expecting to receive his
reward that day he said lord remember me
when you come in your kingdom jesus then
responded said assuredly i sound to you
today you will be with me in paradise
now in the original greek there are no
punctuation there's no commas in the
original greek that came many years
later and depending upon where you put
the comma that can change the context of
that verse that jesus is
the words that jesus is saying you see
jesus was not saying that the thief
would be with him in paradise that day
because you read on sunday morning the
resurrection jesus said i have not yet
ascended to my father in heaven so jesus
didn't go to heaven
the moment he died on friday afternoon
but rather what jesus said to the thief
that day
that he would remember him when he comes
in his kingdom he gave him the assurance
why is that so important when you accept
jesus as your personal savior you have
the assurance that very moment that day
you can have the assurance that god will
remember you
now of course we want to stay connected
to jesus we want to trust in him but we
can we can receive that forgiveness that
very day we don't have to wait there's
no there's no time where you know we
need to prove that we are genuine with
god we can by faith claim the promise
that he wants to give us and that's what
christ was emphasizing to the thief that
day amen and that's luke 23 verse 42 and
43. thanks jeff all right next we have
judy from texas good evening judy
hi good evening pastors thank you so
much for being there to answer our
questions
amen happy to do it i have a question
about genesis 3 6 when the serpent is
enticing
eve in the garden and it says and when
the woman saw that the tree was good for
food and that it was pleasant to the
eyes
and a tree to be desired to make one
wise she took up the fruit thereof and
did eat and gave also and to her husband
with her
and he did eat does this mean he was
when when the serpent was doing his
thing okay good question um the answer
is no he wasn't at the tree when eve was
talking to the serpent apparently eve
sort of wandered off by herself for a
little while we don't know how far adam
was from eve but when it says uh her
husband with her it's referring to in
the garden her companion her friend so
she took her the fruit and she gave it
to adam and we know adam wasn't there
because she brought it to him and she
gave it to him and she said i have eaten
of the fruit you know you need to eat
all the fruit and eventually adam took
an eight so
he wasn't there at the moment when the
devil tempted her but he was in the
garden with her and that's the reference
or that's the emphasis of that verse
that we find there
does that help judy
thanks a lot could i pop in a real quick
when my daughter and my son-in-law
argued with me about how do we know
saturday is the seventh day
anybody could have named
saturday monday or sunday monday all
right i'm having a hard time convincing
them all right let me see if i can
answer this we got just a few seconds
before i break yes the seventh day of
the week is saturday we know that
because jesus died on friday and that's
called the preparation day he rested in
the tomb on saturday and he rose on
sunday which is the first day of the
week
so if you just look at the experience of
jesus and then of course you can ask any
jew what day of the week is the sabbath
and they'll say it's the seventh day
it's saturday and of course the whole
nation of israel has been keeping at
least the orthodox jews have been
keeping the seventh day as the sabbath
so if you look at the jewish nation you
look at the bible you look at the
experience of jesus it makes it quite
clear there's no doubt as to which day
of the week is the seventh day
that would be as we know it today
saturday
well friends you hear the music in the
background the program is not over we're
just taking a short break and we'll come
back with more of your bible questions
so don't go far we'll be right back
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
amazing facts offer some of the best
christian resources for all ages we hope
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the lord
in the blueprint bible lessons
you'll uncover the history of good
versus evil and learn how this ages old
conflict makes sense of our world
and your life
get yours today by calling
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture
egyptians built pyramids to help guide
the spirits of their leaders
rome sanctioned holidays to honor and
appease the spirits of their dead even
the bible tells of a king that used a
witch to contact the spirit of a
deceased prophet
today ancient folklore of spirits and
apparitions have gone from mere
superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality
scientific organizations investigate
stories of hauntings and sightings
trying to prove once and for all
the existence of ghosts
even with all the new found technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world
there is still
no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true
[Music]
why do these stories persist
does it even matter
we invite you to look inside and find
out for yourself
visit ghosttruth.com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 p.m
and 8 p.m pacific time to receive any of
the bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hello friends welcome back this is bible
answers live my name is john ross and
with me this evening is pastor carlos
pastor doug bashley's out this evening
but we are taking your bible questions
live and if you have a bible related
question the phone number to call is
800-463-7297
again that number is
800-463-7297 that'll bring you right in
here to our studio and we will try and
answer as many questions as we can you
know pastor carlos in our break i
actually who are watching what folks are
watching on tv those who are joining us
online and tv and we had a commercial a
commercial for a prophecy seminar that
is going to start october the 15th
called panorama of prophecy we're so
excited about this in this seminar
pastor doug battle he's going to be
looking at some of the most important
some of the most fascinating prophecies
anywhere in scripture you you've got to
be a part of this
if you'd like to learn more about this
panorama of prophecy series just go to
the website panorama of prophecy or you
can just go to the amazing facts website
there's a big banner right on the first
page you can click on that you can
register this is going to be broadcast
live across the country and around the
world it's going to be on youtube social
media on various networks
and paso carlos it's going to be
translated in spanish live yes i wonder
who's going to do that i wonder who it
is right here
yes so i'll be doing a live translation
in spanish so those interested you can
go to panoramaprophecy.com there'll be a
link there also or panorama
okay
all of us spanish-speaking people yes
and that will be live so live spanish
translation it's going to start october
the 15th seven o'clock pacific time so
make a note of that and we hope you'll
be able to join us it's gonna be a
series of presentations
and uh for probably for the next four
weeks or so we're going to be looking at
some of these very important bible
prophecies you won't want to miss them
okay we're going to go to the phone
lines who do we have next we have chi
from new york welcome chi you are on the
air
thank you so much i want to know what
the bible says in first peter chapter 3
19 and 20.
all right well when i read it for for
those who are driving
verse 19 says by whom also he went and
preached to the spirits in prison
who formerly were disobedient when once
the divine long suffering waited in the
days of noah
while the ark was being prepared in
which few that his eight souls were
saved through the water
so you're probably wondering about these
spirits in prison
yeah i was i was trying to minister to
one of my friends and he brought up this
particular scripture i couldn't explain
it
okay great question well in order to
understand what peter is talking about
here we need to read the previous verse
which is verse 18. so i started reading
verse 19 but i'm going to start now in
verse 18 and you'll get the context and
then it begins to make sense it says for
christ also suffered once for sin the
just for the unjust that he might bring
us to god
being put to death in the flesh
but made alive by the spirit
now i want to pause right there the
subject that peter is addressing here in
this passage is the spirit the holy
spirit the holy spirit that made christ
alive
and then ephray says in verse 19 by whom
by whom that is the spirit by whom he
jesus went and preached
to the spirits in prison
that were disobedient
in the days before the flood or in the
days before noah and you can read the
rest of the verse there so what's been
addressed here is that jesus was
resurrected by the same spirit that he
preached to the antediluvian world so
those living before the flood the holy
spirit was preaching to them
and it was christ through the spirit
that was preaching to them
and how do we know that well we read the
account in genesis where the bible says
my spirit shall not always strive with
man but his day shall be 120 years
so during that time period the holy
spirit was striving with those before
the flood but they hardened their heart
now it was the spirit of god it was in
essence christ through the spirit that
was appealing to them asking them to
come to repentance they refused and so
the bible goes on in verse 20 to tell us
that only eight souls were saved that
would be noah and his family so it's not
talking about when jesus died his
disembodied spirits somehow went down
into hell to the people that were there
before the flood there's a whole
doctrine that's been built on a
misapplication of the phrase the first
verse in verse 18 which talks about the
spirit it's the holy spirit that he's
been emphasized and the holy spirit did
speak to the people before the flood
yeah i think there's a great verse also
in isaiah 42
6-7 it says talking the father about the
son i have given you as a covenant as
light to the gentiles and isaiah 42 7
says to open blind eyes and to bring out
prisoners from the prison
so it's the imprisonment of the mind to
slavery to sin that's right liberating
us and of course that's part of the
mission of jesus that i've come to set
the captives free amen well he didn't
break down any prison doors but
spiritually speaking he set the captives
of sinfree amen and that's really what's
been addressed during the verse does
that help but she
yeah it helped a lot thank you so much
are you welcome thanks for your call
thank you very much next we have jerry
from rocky place georgia good evening
jerry the bible answers live
good evening to you
hey i've just wondered
about john the gospel of john chapter 10
verse 34 when i was
uh wondering what y'all thought about
but you might want to start with 33 34
and 35 yeah all right thanks jerry i'm
going to read it for those who are
driving in their car um i'll start over
here in
in verse let me start in verse 32 just
so we get the context jesus answered
them christ is having a discussion with
the religious leaders of his day
many good works i have shown you from my
father for which of these do you stone
me and then they respond verse 33 the
jews answered and said for a good work
we do not stone you but for blasphemy
and because you being a man make
yourself god
so christ would refer to himself as
being the i am or christ would sometimes
say i am the way the truth the life and
the religious leaders said ah this is
blasphemy if you claim to be able to
forgive sins or if you claim titles that
belong to god well biblically speaking
is blasphemy now it was not blasphemy
for jesus for he is god he is the son of
god
but there was this dispute and verse 34
jesus answered them and said it is
is it not written in your law i said you
are god's
if he called them gods to whom the word
of god came and the scriptures cannot be
broken do you say of him whom the father
sanctified and sent into the world you
are blaspheming because i said i am the
son of god
so he's referring to an old testament
passage i believe in psalms
where it refers to people as being gods
but it's with a small g it's not a
capital g it's not referring to the
divinity
but there was certain rulership or
lordship
another word for translation that is
lord or overseer
so christ is saying you're condemning me
because i'm calling myself the son of
god and yet i have been sanctified by
the father my works prove that i am the
son of god and he says but you claim to
go by the law but the law refers to
people as being rulers or overseers or
lords and yet you're wanting to condemn
me for being me for being a ruler or an
overseer or a lord
in essence jesus was just turning the
situation back on them
because they were accusing him of
something that he didn't do
that's his and that's in psalms 82 6.
uh did that help a little jerry
yeah that helped some there you know but
uh i just wondered about of course i got
the old king james version and the gods
when he said ye are gods
it's all capital letters of course i
know we're not god you can't be right
exactly
we're not even close to god right when
it's translated the new king james and
even actually over here in john it's all
small case gods
so it's not referring to the one and
only true god remember the pagans the
nations surrounding israel they also had
deities or gods
and they had overseers and lords and i
think a better word there for god if you
go back into the original hebrew has to
do with rulership or lordship
that's really actually the word elohim
ruler yeah okay judge judge
okay well thanks jerry uh who do we have
next christopher from huntington park
good evening you're on the air
good evening pastor ross yes i have a
question
it's regarding the
uh mixed fabrics
okay uh i just want to i just want to
know if they're part of the ceremonial
loss or the moral loss and if they are
part of the ceremonial laws are they
done away then okay great question all
right let me give you a little
background for those who might be
listening in the old testament we have
different categories of law you have for
example the moral law we call that the
ten commandments of course the ten
commandments are still binding it's
still wrong to steal or kill or commit
adultery he's always been wrong eve
broke one of the ten commandments
actually more than one when she took of
the fruit that god said don't take and
eat she broke the commandment that said
i shall not steal she coveted that's the
tenth commandment she gave to a husband
who ate thou shalt not murder or kill so
you can look at all different types of
ten commandments that she broke so
you've got the moral law the ten
commandments it's always been in effect
you have the civil laws the civil laws
govern the nation of israel the
principles of the civil law if followed
by
civil authorities tend to a more
prosperous happier people
many of the
nations of western europe the christian
nations especially the protestant
nations that were founded on
protestantism they prospered because
they followed a number of the principles
found in
in the civil code that we find in the
old testament not all of it applies
today because god was the direct king or
ruler of israel it's a little different
in our situation then you have the
health laws and of course the health
laws would relate to being healthy and
practical and yes you don't want to eat
those things that aren't clean and
there's some practical aspects of that
and so of course that's applicable today
but then you have the ceremonial laws
and the ceremonial law had to do with
the priesthood it had to do with the
sanctuary you had to do the sacrifice
but they were also connected with the
ceremonial or some additional customs
that the people were to follow here
specifically one of the regulations not
to wear clothes of mixed fabrics and the
reason for that is because god wanted to
make a distinction between his people
and the pagan nations around them one of
the things the pagan nations would do is
they would have mixed fabrics in their
clothing they would shave their beards
in a certain way as a sign of worship
for the dead there were many different
customs that god said no don't have any
part of it i'm going to separate you're
going to be a different people now we
can take the principle of that and we
can apply that today should christians
dress differently than the world
i believe so not that we should be
fanatical but there should be a
cleanliness
there should be a modesty that is found
with christians that he's different from
the world so you can apply a principle
there but no there is nothing wrong
in having a shirt made of cotton and
polyester other than it's probably
uncomfortable i don't know but it seems
like everything nowadays has got a
little bit of polyester in it but no
you're not biking breaking any biblical
a law uh by doing so
does that help christopher
yeah can i ask you a quick question yeah
real quick
when you say about the mixed fabrics are
you saying that we cannot mix
plant with animal fabrics
no no you can i mean today we've got to
be practical some fabrics do very well
when you mix them um you're talking
about like wool and cotton
well what i'm talking about like spandex
can work spandex recording and polyester
oh yeah yeah you know i think the
principle here is there needs to be a
distinction between the dress of the
christian
and the dress of the world and and that
was the point that was being emphasized
by these ceremonial laws of the old
testament christ or god wanted the
israelites to look differently and to
dress differently than the pagan nations
around them
and so that's why we have these these
principles practical principles that
were applied but today no there's
nothing wrong in in wearing clothes of
mixed fabric but we do want to follow
the principle of modesty
okay i appreciate it thank you all right
you're welcome thanks christopher next
we have sherry from wisconsin good
evening sherry you are on the air
hi pastors
um my question
is
in
job 3 about leviathan
yes and i'm
i'm wondering
if that creature is
related to
the creatures in revelation
or was there it's my understanding that
job was one of the first books written
yes
and
if that's true
was there
a world before us
that
through the creature and the bottomless
pit okay yeah let me let me see if i can
give you a little more information when
you read in the book of job you read
about several creatures the one being
leviathan and the other one called
behemoth these are two animals that
you know we don't have an exact likeness
today
if you look at the characteristics for
example of the behemoth it really looks
like
some kind of a dinosaur he's got big
round legs that look like the legs of an
elephant but he has a big thick tail
and he's got a long strong neck and he
lives by the reeds
so what job is referring to is animals
that existed before the flood
many of these animals were destroyed in
the flood and of course we had the
fossil record to back that up and
leviathan for the most part could have
been some kind of a sea
going dinosaur that existed before the
flood we just got you know the fossil
remains of that
job being an old book it's possible that
there were still stories around of these
great monsters or sea creatures
maybe even at the time some survived the
flood and they were around of course
today they would be extinct so now they
were real animals although
in the book of revelation you also read
about different creatures and beasts
but
those are symbolic for example it talks
about one beast that has seven heads
and ten horns well there's no animal
today that has seven heads and ten homes
so that's clearly symbolic but what's
described here in job it sounds like a
real animal that existed and uh if you
go back to the fossil record before the
flood yeah there were these giant
animals that lived on the earth
and in the sea
job asks guys
um
about
being prepared to rouse verizon
yeah in other words who can go up
against leviathan i mean he's a great
powerful sea like creature and who can
try and take it on now it is interesting
that a dragon
in the bible symbolizes the devil
leviathan was a giant reptile of some
kind
maybe it was a symbol for the devil but
in the context of job it was a real
animal because he goes on not only talk
about behemoth and not only talk about
leviathan but to talk about other
animals that are very common even today
so it's a description of some of these
creatures that that god made that lived
before the flood and i think that's
that's the point that's been emphasized
there
so uh thanks thanks for your question
all right next we have becky from texas
good evening becky you are on the air
uh yeah hello how are you doing hi becky
we're blessed uh
yeah my question is concerning um
when there has been a gender change
uh
surgically
and
you know the person as a male but then
has become a female
and um
are you wondering what would be the the
proper christian approach or or response
to a person like that you know it's kind
of interesting that we even have these
discussions today i mean 50 60 years ago
you couldn't get or maybe you could i
don't know surgeries to try and change
your gender i think the bottom line is
um
god loves everyone and god can reach
everyone
and homosexuality although it is
a son that the bible condemns
it can be forgiven and a person can
repent and i know of people who have
lived that lifestyle but they come to
know christ and they have confessed
their sins and they've changed their
lifestyle
i think we want to build a relationship
with a person to try and win them over
to christ but there's a delicate balance
between respecting them but not
necessarily agreeing with those things
that they are doing
that is wrong and it's not just this
particular area
of sin but any sin uh you know i know
people who
want to honor their parents but perhaps
their parents are doing things that are
wrong or a violation of the ten
commandments how do you how do you walk
that line between honoring your parents
and yet not participating or supporting
or endorsing the things that they are
doing that you know is wrong and so
that's where we need to pray for wisdom
and guidance on an individual basis we
want to be christ-like in the way we
interact with people
jesus ministered to them and i think we
need to see in every person
a soul
that christ died for in other words we
want to reach every person with the good
news of salvation and try and encourage
them so you're going to pray for wisdom
that that is a tough question a
difficult situation
and um you know each case is going to be
a little different pastor carlos but i
think that's where we need to pray and
ask god to guide us and help us amen
just loving them and letting the holy
spirit do the holy spirit do what he
only can do well thanks for your call
becky who do we have next abigail from
georgia good evening to and welcome to
bible answers live
um my question is
um
if ally just went to heaven like the
heaven where god dwells
um did he see god when even if the bible
says that no man saw god or has seen him
yeah yes elijah was taken to heaven he
was taken up to where god is because
you're reading the gospels that elijah
and moses appeared with jesus in the
mount of transfiguration
so if elijah and moses were in heaven of
course moses died he was resurrected
according to jude and he was taken to
heaven
if they're in heaven i'm sure they
they're able to see god the verse you're
referring to is in john chapter 3 where
jesus says no man is ascended up into
heaven and come back down except the son
of man he's speaking about himself so
what christ is referencing there is that
he's the one that has brought the truth
from heaven he's the one that has come
to earth to reveal what god is like in
his fullness in his glory
um
is
which one
john 1 18.
yes yes yes okay let me read the verse
just before
it talks about the law or came through
moses but grace and truth came from
jesus christ no one has seen god at any
time the only begotten of the father who
is in the bosom the father he has
declared him again that reference to
seeing god is not just seeing god but
it's seeing to reveal god in other words
nobody has revealed god but the son
that's the spiritual application of that
for example the disciples said to jesus
show us the father and it suffices us
and jesus says he who has seen me has
seen the father
so when it's saying no one has seen the
father it's not just visually it's not
just seeing him but it's seeing and
revealing seeing to show the father only
christ can show us what the father is
really like
oh okay thank you so much for answering
my question guys all right you're
welcome thanks for calling next we have
milo from rhode island milo you are on
the air
hey how are you blessed how are you
i'm gonna know
that's a question in regards to um
companionship for a young
adult male um i'm in my mid-20s
recently born again
and uh
seeking for a companion
in this world um just wanted to know
whether god will provide one for me or
do i have to do the soul-searching
myself oh okay good question of course
there's nothing wrong to seek a
companion to seek a spouse
marriage is honorable or something that
god gave
but we do want to be very wise and
careful in choosing a spouse and that's
where we want to pray and ask god to
lead
marrying the wrong person can be
many people know it can be a very
difficult thing marrying the right
person someone who loves the lord can
actually enhance your spiritual growth
with christ and draw you closer to him
so what part do we have to play you know
i think we want to pray for guidance and
wisdom but there's nothing wrong in
getting to know people or befriending
people some of the guidelines that the
bible does speak of it says don't be
unequally yoked
so don't go out looking for somebody
that doesn't believe in christ or he's
not a christian it doesn't hold your
religious beliefs or doesn't understand
the bible in the way that you understand
it
because you're creating problems for
yourself so find a good christian person
somebody that loves the lord somebody
that shares your ideals um it is nothing
wrong past the course i know of some
folks who are happily married uh
wonderful christians and they found each
other on
a christian uh dating site yeah a single
site so there's nothing wrong with that
god can work through that as well but
you do want to pray and ask god for
guidance and wisdom and then just lay it
all before the lord and say lord is this
the one that you want me to marry in the
holy spirit will lead god will convict
us if our hearts are sincere and we want
it to do his will all right i think we
have time for one or two more passing
cars all right let's go quickly jerry
from paradise michigan you're good
evening you're on the air
yes hi can you hear me okay because i'm
calling from off-grid yeah no we can
hear you
i've heard all my life just saying that
god helps those who help themselves but
i've heard recently that that's not
scriptural
and that it's more truthful to say god
helps those who cannot help themselves
can you shed any light on the truth of
either these or are they a supposition
yeah absolutely uh the the thought god
helps those who help themselves is not
found in the bible i think that was
benjamin franklin if i'm not wrong or
one of those
famous uh writers that mentioned that
but you know the principle we find in
the bible is that god helps those who
recognize their need of help
he doesn't just help those who can't
help themselves he helps those who
recognize their need of help and they
turn to him for help that's the key so
in one sense here you do need to help
yourself in that you need to turn to god
those who don't turn to god they don't
receive the help that god wants to give
them but at the end of the day if we
turn to god and we trust in him when we
ask him for help especially in spiritual
things he will help us without a doubt
he will help us so hope that helps a
little bit jerry yeah uh god will help
those who recognize they need and turn
to him for help that's the condition i
think we have time for one more one more
marlin good evening you're on the air
oh uh thank you for taking my call uh
pastor carl pastor ross um i my question
was that i heard uh in one of uh pastor
doug batchelor's uh
sermons to the children from a few years
back
that there is a varying amount of time
uh for your duration in hell based on
uh
like what your sins were
um it all results in death but the
amount of time that you spend there uh
changes depending on your sins and i was
wondering where where that came from
okay yes let me share a few thoughts of
course the end result of all sin is
death and that is eternal death but god
does reward both the righteous and the
unrighteous according to their deeds
there are varying rewards you find in
luke chapter 12 verse 40
8 it says those who have committed
things deserving stripes and did not
know
they were given few stripes but those
who knew better and i'm paraphrasing
because of time
they were given more so god is fair and
just even in the punishment of the
wicked but is also going to reward
people
on the other side on the good side based
upon their service and their devotion
and their love for him everyone gets
eternal life but there are still varying
degrees of reward that we read about in
revelation chapter 22. so luke 12 48 and
revelation 22. friends don't go away
we'll be right back
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
hello friends welcome back to one of our
best parts of bible answers live we're
going to try and answer as many of your
questions that have come in via email so
pastor carlos how many questions do we
have this evening let's go for it what's
the worst five questions here uh this is
connie she's asking my nephew says the
bible is fictional how do you know there
is a god how do you know that there's a
god well first of all you've got to read
the bible the bible reveals to us that
there is a god how do you know the bible
is true well the bible reveals prophecy
prophecy reveals the future and if you
look back in the bible and you can see
how accurately the bible predicted
things that took place that will
strengthen your faith in the word of god
and when you trust the word of god it'll
lead you to the god of the word which is
god the savior jesus christ all right
next we have a question from let me see
if i do this correctly nazi okay very
good right i think so
why did god forgive satan and what sin
can we partake in today that god cannot
forgive okay why didn't god forgive
satan and is there a sin that we can
commit that god cannot forgive well
satan committed that sin that god cannot
forgive and the bible refers to that as
the unpardonable sin it is the sin
against the holy spirit it's when a
person hardens their heart to the point
where they don't even hear the
promptings of the holy spirit their
conscience in essence have been deadened
the bible tells us it's the goodness of
god that leads a person to repentance so
if we've rejected the spirit of god that
leads us to repentance how do we come to
a point of repentance and if we don't
repent how can we be forgiven
so yes there is a sin
for which there is no forgiveness and
that is the sin of rejection against the
holy spirit or the unpardonable sin
satan has committed that sin next is
from jaisami
in the book of job it talks about the
sons of god gathering before god as well
as satan who are the sons of god okay
short answer on this one the sons of god
are the representatives of the unfallen
worlds
psalms talks about the elders as a group
of people that are there in heaven how
do we know that they're the
representatives of the unfallen worlds
because you're reading job that the
devil shows up and god says where did
you come from and he says oh from
walking up and down on the earth so we
know this gathering was not on the earth
there was some other place probably in
heaven and the devil came representing
the earth and saying well you know
that's my domain now that's my kingdom
and god says well if you notice there's
someone in your kingdom that really
belongs in my kingdom and you have the
whole story of job but we believe these
sons of god are these representatives of
these different realms these worlds that
you read about in hebrews chapter 1. all
right last quest quickly what did christ
mean when he said we must be born again
to be born again we have to accept jesus
as our personal savior we confess our
sins we ask for the holy spirit to do a
work in us that only he can do and just
as surely as we do that god is faithful
he'll forgive us and he'll cleanse us
friends thank you for joining us for
bible answers live look forward to
seeing you next week
you